chers amis je vous propose de reprendre
vos places pour accueillir les
intervenants de la seconde table ronde
ils auront besoin de toute votre
attention pour les minutes qui viennent
nous allons à nouveau débattre de ces
trois thèmes qui sont notre fil
conducteur protéger libérer rassembler
et c'est sur les questions d action
législatives concrètes dont vous allez
pouvoir échanger c'est autour d'agnès
evren que je vous demande d'accueillir
par un tonnerre d'applaudissements
député européen et porte parole des
républicains charlotte vaio vice
présidents des républiques est des
jeunes républicains et sébastien canovas
responsable des jeunes de haute garonne
ils débattront autour de damien abad
président du groupe l'est républicain à
l'assemblée nationale et françois-xavier
bellamy président de notre groupe au
parlement européen
avant que ne débute la table ronde je
suis très heureux de lancer la vidéo de
bruno retailleau qui ne pouvais pas être
avec nous et qui a tenu à vous adresser
un message que nous allons écouter
j'étais avec vos meilleurs mais je n'ai
pas pu être présents parmi vous
aujourd'hui et j'ai voulu vous adresser
un message ce message est double car
c'est à la fois un message d'exigence et
un message d'espérance un message
d'exigence parce que c'est ce que vous
incarnez autour de votre président
guilhem une exigence celle des
convictions votre génération exige une
droite pierre ils bradent forte une
droite qui s'assume et vous avez raison
vous avez raison parce que les
convictions c'est ce qui donne du sens à
l'action politique c'est ce qui fait sa
grandeur c'est ce qui fait sa profondeur
mais aussi et surtout parce que tout ce
que nous vivons exige la force de nos
convictions
vous voyez bien la situation de la
france de notre pays est telle que nous
ne pouvons plus nous contenter de demi
mesures
ce message c'est aussi un message
d'espérance parce que en 2022 nous
pouvons battre emmanuel macron nous
pouvons parce qu'une majorité de
français refusent son duel avec marine
le pen mais surtout nous pouvons parce
que la france est majoritairement tout
droit elle veut le retour de l'autorité
la défense de nos libertés
la fierté nationale c'est ce que veulent
les français et c'est ce qu'il me
demande alors donnons leur ce qu'ils
demandent tenant aux français cette
droite d'exigence pour redonner à la
france une espérance en nous rassemblant
bien sûr parce qu'on ne gagne jamais
seul en nous rassemblant évidemment
aussi dans la clarté et non pas dans la
confusion autour d'un projet puissant et
cohérent il nous reste huit mois mais
mois pour convaincre mais moi pour nous
battre huit mois pour vaincre nous
pouvons nous le devons pas seulement
pour notre parti mais pour notre pays
celui que nous servons celui que nous
aimons alors vive les jeunes
républicains vivent cette génération
d'espérance d'exigence engagés pour la
france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous on va vous demander un
peu de concentration si vous vouliez
bien
reprendre regagnez vos places s'il vous
plaît
pour écouter ce passionnant échanges que
nous allons avoir avec damien abad
françois-xavier bellamy et christine
lagarde
vous dire d'abord que évidemment c'est
important de saluer votre présence
nombreuse depuis deux jours et vous
incarnez vous incarnez le rassemblement
des français de tous les âges et de tous
les territoires que nous souhaitons
porter au sein de notre famille les
républicains vous êtes énormément de
talent et nous pouvons donc désormais
compter sur la relève je voudrais dire
un mot d'abord sur guilhem car ayant
parce que vous savez j'ai toujours pensé
que la politique c'était d'abord et
avant tout une affaire de comportement
et il faut dire que guilhem fait preuve
de beaucoup d'humilité et c'est une
qualité très rare en politique qui
mérite d'être souligné et qui mérite
d'être applaudi bravo guilhem pour ton
humilité
qui fait beaucoup de bien aux politiques
et qu'ils gagneraient aussi à toucher ce
gouvernement qui manque tellement
d'humilité tellement de modestie je
voudrais également remercier notre cher
président christian jacob sans qui nous
ne serions pas là aujourd'hui
pour vous présenter ce projet parce que
c'est son un pc sous son impulsion que
nous avons réuni tous ses forums parce
que nous avions la conviction que cette
reconquête du pouvoir viendra évidemment
par les idées par le fonds est donc
merci mon cher christian d'avoir
stimuler d'avoir permis donc cette
construction d'un projet qui serait un
projet d'alternance à un match de la
présidentielle dans dont nous ne voulons
pas celui d' emmanuel macron contre
marine le pen et doute devons et nous
pouvons gagner cette présidentielle
alors
eh bien aujourd'hui en france un
impératif national de rassembler et ça a
été parfaitement de biens dits par
rachida rassemblés après un quinquennat
de fracturation de notre société
d'exacerbation des inégalités sociales
et territoriales et d'explosion des
extrémismes il est vrai que la france
n'a jamais été aussi morcelé entre les
opinions entre les territoires entre les
générations et la réponse elle doit
venir d'en haut la réponse elle doit
venir du sommet de l'état or nous voyons
bien qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux on le
voit bien sur les trois ans de la mort
du quinquennat qui seront l'objet
d'ailleurs de ce débat il est tout
simplement encore une fois dans le flou
et on a le sentiment que ce en même
temps conduit finalement à un nul part
et donc il est important de pouvoir
aujourd'hui avoir un projet qui apporte
des réponses aux français sur les trois
angles morts de ce quinquennat parce que
quand on entend le président dira qu'il
ne croit pas à l'existence d'une culture
française quand on l'entend dire qu'il
faut déconstruire l'histoire de france
alors ils participent aussi c'est pour
ça qu'il n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux à cette fracturation de notre
société française et à l'archipel
isation de la société il ya trois ans
glement et c'est pour ça que je vous
demanderais mon cher damien françois
xavier et ma chère christine de répondre
sur la façon dont nous allons mettre en
oeuvre notre projet premier angle mort
évidemment c'est le régalien nous sommes
de droite et sur le régalien nous avons
le sentiment d'un président de la
république qui n'a jamais rêvé
véritablement cru auraient gagné qui
n'est fondamentalement pas à l'aise sur
ces questions régaliennes évidemment
là dessus nous avons des propositions
extrêmement importante alors que la
mission fondamentale du président de la
république c'est d'assurer la sécurité
la défense et la justice et bien sur ces
sujets-là ce en même temps n'a pas été à
londres à la hauteur des enjeux
deuxièmement évidemment sur les
questions économiques on voit bien
qu'aucune dépense publique n'a été
aucune réduction des dépenses publiques
n'a été fait aucune réforme structurelle
n'a été entreprise et la france conjugue
aujourd'hui un chômage massif et un
endettement infinie et enfin un autre
sujet qui nous tient très à coeur dans
deux familles politiques ce sont
évidemment les la réduction des
fractures territoriales
il y a un mépris pour les territoires
est le symbole de ce mépris pour les
territoires évidemment c'est tout
simplement la taxe carbone et les 80
kilomètres/heure alors nous avons une
heure et quart pour vous dire quels sont
justement nos propositions et comment
nous allons les mettre en oeuvre quand
nous arriverons à la tête du pauvre
c'est pour ça je vais vous demander à
tous les trois que les chances soient le
plus dynamique possible un échange ping
pong pour que ce ça permette à tous ceux
qui sont ici présents de ne pas repartir
frustré doté de cette salle et que
toutes les questions puissent être posée
est évidemment obtenir des réponses donc
j'ai la chance d'animer cet atelier avec
sébastien que je vous demande
d'applaudir qu'elle rdj de haute garonne
[Musique]
et charlotte bayod qui est la vice
présidente des jeunes républicains que
je vous demande d'applaudir également
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà donc je vais donner la parole à
l'un d'entre vous à celui qui commence
qui souhaitent commencer évidemment on
leur dira que damien l'assemblée fait un
travail absolument extraordinaire à la
tête 204 députés il travaille
d'arrache-pied sur le législatif pour
faire des contre-propositions et ne pas
être dans la critique systématique et
donc qu'on cher damien bravo pour ce
groupe que tu portes avec beaucoup de
cohésion de cohérence et est aussi
d'inventivité parce qu'il en faut
françois-xavier évidemment qui est notre
chef de délégation au parlement européen
qui fait un travail extrêmement brillant
au sein de notre délégation et christine
qui porte avec beaucoup de talent et
d'intelligence notre projet avec olivier
marchal ex donc si vous le voulez bien
je peux vous donner une minute trente la
parole mais véritablement l'idc d'un
échange ping pong avec la salle encore
une fois pour que personne ne repart
frustré de cette salle et à 12h55
j'interromps prennent aux travaux parce
que nous avons un déjeuner à 13 heures
damien vous aviez ou christine
allez mon cher damien à toi la parole
bon c'est bonjour à toutes et à tous
d'abord avant de avant de débuter chez
agnès si tu perds mais je voudrais
saluer tous nos jeunes qui sont présents
le dimanche matin c'est toujours plus
difficile en général que les autres
jours merci à vous parce que
vous vous êtes pas simplement des jeunes
sur internet vous êtes des jeunes
présents au concret qui défendent tout
simplement le quotidien des français et
c'était un vrai pari avec christian
jacob avec gérard larcher avec annie et
toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont là
que de remobiliser ce mouvement jeune
donc je voudrais d'abord tirer mon
chapeau à guillem carillon et aussi à
notre président du parti christian jacob
parce que si on est là ce soir
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à eux
vous savez c'est essentiel d'abord parce
que la jeunesse c'est pas forcément un
état qui dure ça peut durer dans
l'esprit et surtout parce que c'est vous
qui pouvez créer ce mouvement politique
dont on a besoin et ses idées qu'on doit
porter ensemble vous interrogez es-tu
m'interroge ferragne est sûre sur
finalement les trois angles morts il y
en a tellement de ce quinquennat
j'aurais juste pour être très rapide et
et ouvrir le débat vous dire deux choses
d'abord j'ai beaucoup de chance de
présider un groupe 204 députés à
l'assemblée nationale nous sommes le
premier groupe d'opposition je le dis
sous le contrôle d'eni genevard et
toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont là
jamais jamais le parlement français n'a
été aussi affaiblie que sous l'ère des
manuels macron ça c'est une réalité
parce qu'on n'a jamais eu une telle
fracture et finalement de tel député à
la fois déconnectés de la réalité du
terrain mais aussi qui n'était pas en
capacité de porter des projets
politiques en temps et donc nous ce que
nous faisons au quotidien à l'assemblée
nationale c'est de porter des
propositions c'est de porter des idées
nouvelles bien entendu c'est aussi de
faire des contre projets on a fait sur
la réforme des retraites on en a fait
dans la lutte contre le séparatisme
l'islamisme radical sur l'économie
l'entreprise sur l'écologie parce que
l'écologie c'est quelque chose que nous
devons pas abandonner au vert comme
disait clemenceau la guerre est quelque
chose de trop sérieuse pour l'abandonner
aux militaires et 20 d'écologie quelque
chose de trop sérieux pour l'abandonner
au vert également et c'est à nous aussi
à droite de porter ce message là et de
le faire entendre
et d'expliquer à tout le monde en dehors
que oui on peut être de droite et porter
haut et fort les couleurs
d'environnement et vouloir protéger
notre notre nature et puis bien sûr
c'est aussi eux c'est aussi la fracture
territoriale que tu as évoqué sur tous
ces sujets à chaque fois on a essayé
d'intervenir de faire des propositions
de montrer tout simplement aux uns et
aux autres que nous on était une force
d'alternance qu'on était là pour et bien
je l'espère demain reprendre les rênes
de notre pays et surtout pour sortir de
ce en même temps paralysant qui créent
de l'immobilisme qui créent de
l'impuissance équiperait de l'inaction
permanente alors oui je peux vous le
dire si certains français ne sont pas
encore convaincus quand vous êtes au
parlement car vous présidez le premier
groupe à l'assemblée nationale
d'opposition
vous dites qu'une chose c'est que jamais
jamais la droite ne pourra se fondre
dans le maquereau 10 parce que nous
n'avons pas le même adn politique
n'avons pas la même culture et nous a
pas de la même façon de penser les
choses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bonjour à tous donc je vais être
assez vrai puisque finalement vous
m'avez déjà entendu hier pour dire un
peu quelles sont nos grandes priorités
mais le sujet de cette table ronde s'est
libéré protéger rassembler avec quels
moyens alors bien évidemment vous avez
tous en tête ici forcément les moyens
financiers mais j'ai envie de faire
passer le message que ce ne sont pas
forcément les seuls moyens aujourd'hui
la politique c'est aussi l'art de
choisir d'établir des priorités et je
pense que nous avons un devoir de vérité
vis-à-vis des français c'est-à-dire ne
pas promettre tout et n'importe quoi
mais de promettre uniquement ce que nous
serons en capacité de faire pendant cinq
ans ce que nous saurons aussi en
capacité de faire parce que notre
économie notre société pourra le faire
donc c'est là ça nous ensemble de
définir quelles sont ses priorités sur
lesquelles nous voulons nous battre et
nous voulons nous différencier aussi de
ce qui pourrait être des pis-aller des
faux semblants voilà à côté donc c'est
ce qui sait ce qu'on doit encore faire
ensemble cet avant projet il donne les
grandes lignes des grandes idées après
il nous faut affiner ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et d'abord merci
infiniment pour cette occasion vous nous
donnez d'échangé c'est une joie de vous
retrouver ce matin et de vous voir en
pleine forme hier soir je doutais un peu
en vous voyant que vous seriez si
nombreux mais vous montrez que vous avez
une énergie inépuisable
et c'est justement de celle là dont on
aura besoin pour relever les grands
défis de cette année pour les relevés
unis autour de notre famille politique
avec christian jacob et moi aussi je
voudrais le remercier de tenir la barre
dans la tempête
[Musique]
avec tout avec toute l'équipe qui
l'entourent avec tous nos amis je crois
que le rendez vous de ce matin il est
magnifique aussi parce que c'est un
rendez-vous de l'unité c'est un rendez
vous de l'amitié cette année les jeunes
républicains ont vécu un débat on peut
en parler c'est un débat qui a permis de
créer un dialogue et au fond aujourd'hui
nous sommes tous unis nous sommes tous
rassemblés c'est la preuve que les
jeunes républicains donnent une leçon à
notre famille politique on peut discuter
on peut avoir des approches divergentes
nous croyons à la démocratie nous
croyons à la vitalité du dialogue et
nous sommes là tous ensemble aujourd'hui
je suis très heureux d'être sur cette
scène avec sébastien avec charlotte et
de dire un immense bravo un immense
merci à guilhem pour l'organisation de
ces journées pour tout le travail qui
fait à la tête des jeunes républicains
[Musique]
et c'est aussi cette unité qui fait
notre force autour de christian jacob
avec nos groupes parlementaires avec le
groupe au sénat avec bruno retailleau
avec le groupe à l'assemblée damien on a
la chance de travailler ensemble souvent
et puis avec notre délégation au
parlement européen avec agnès avec tous
nos collègues tout ce que je voudrais
vous dire ce matin avant de rentrer dans
le concret c'est que on a pu compter sur
vous on sait pouvoir compter sur vous
les jeunes républicains vous devez être
sûr que vous pouvez compter sur nous que
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour porter
votre voix pour relayer vos
préoccupations pour défendre votre
engagement hier j'ai parlé avec beaucoup
d'entre vous et ça m'a marqué de voir à
quel point vous suivez ce que nous
faisons eh bien je voudrais vous dire
que tout ce que nous faisons c'est pour
essayer d'être à la hauteur de tout ce
que vous avez donné dans toutes les
campagnes qui ont vu les élections
passées qui ont vu notre famille
politique reprendre des couleurs et je
crois que c'est très important de
pouvoir vous dire que nous ne comptons
pas seulement sur vous pour mener des
campagnes difficiles que nous sommes là
aussi pour défendre vos couleurs et que
nous avons besoin de vous pour que vous
puissiez être la relève dont la france
aura besoin dans les années qui
viendront et tout ce que nous avons à
faire nous c'est de vous aider à grandir
de vous aider à prendre des
responsabilités de vous aider à vous
engager de plus en plus tout ce projet
dont on va parler il a aussi pour but de
préparer notre avenir et c'est ensemble
avec vous que nous le préparons
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
tellement important de pouvoir échanger
ensemble et je partage ce que tu faisais
agnès le plus important c'est qu'on
puisse discuter qu'on puisse partager à
partir de vos questions de vos remarques
de vos interrogations de tout ce que
vous portez vous aussi et de tout ce
dont nous pourrons nous faire le relais
dans les mois qui viendront et dans les
années qui viendront à l'occasion de
cette belle victoire qui j'en suis sûr
nous attend pour l'élection
présidentielle à venir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup alors on va prendre une
série de cinq premières questions
honneur d'abord à sébastien est
également et charlotte et ensuite trois
questions dans la salle et on va
continuer comme ça pour que tout soit
très dynamique je t'en prie sébastien
première question
alors comme l'a dit agnès notre famille
z est un tournant et pour prendre ce
tournant il faut s'appuyer sur notre
histoire l'histoire de cette famille qui
qui nous a permis
comme l'a montré de gaulle pompidou
chirac est bien évidemment un sarkozy
ils avaient tous un point commun celui
d'une france ambitieuse une france ancré
sur ses territoires et en écho avec les
attentes des français
chirac disait que la politique ce n'est
pas lui sur un courant et de fixer un
cap et on est là aujourd'hui présents
pour fixer ce cap avec vous c'est notre
héritage et notre devoir de protéger les
français notre devoir de les libérer
mais c'est surtout notre devoir de les
rassembler rassembler notre famille
politique rassemblée la jeunesse comme
vous avez su le faire aujourd'hui et
avant tout rassembler les français je
suis convaincu qu'en rentrant hier soir
10 heures du matin vous avez tous lu le
pré projet présidentiel
mais
je propose quand même de demander à
notre cher député monsieur damien abad
de nous présenter ce nouveau projet de
société que nous allons proposer aux
français et que
l'engouement qu'on a pu écrire je mens
de campagne merci sébastien charlotte à
petit mot et ensuite je donne la parole
à la salle oui alors moi comme on est à
la rentrée des jeunes républicains
aujourd'hui je souhaitais vous poser une
question sur l'éducation plus
particulièrement et je m'adresse surtout
à françois-xavier parce que je sais que
tu as fait quelques propositions sur ce
thème là alors ma question est simple
comment devons-nous réformer l'éducation
nationale pour proposer une meilleure
formation aux jeunes enfants
offrir de meilleures conditions de
travail aux professeurs et enfin comment
offrir des solutions aux jeunes afin
qu'ils puissent accéder à des études
supérieures et à l'ascenseur social
merci charlotte j'ai noté ces deux
premières questions trois questions dans
la seule
je vois des mains qui se lèvent là bas à
droite faut aller au micro il ya des
micros des deux côtés de la salle pour
aller poser vos questions n'hésitez pas
à les poser vos questions là bas s'il
vous plaît
allez-y je vous en prie
présentez-vous juste le département et
votre nom bonjour mathilde rimaud de
l'essonne moi je suis ingénieur sûreté
nucléaire pour reparler un tout petit
peu plus fort ce qu'elle est je vais
mettre plus précis
ma question concerne l'autorité puisque
il était dit c'est quelque chose que
kick it qui est important pour la droite
c'est restaurer restaurer l'autorité de
l'état
l'autorité c'est quelque chose
essentielle pour diriger un groupe à
tous les niveaux que ce soit dans une
entreprise ou à l'échelle d'un pays mais
je considère que l'autorité ne va pas
sans la confiance et on voit que la
confiance dans les instituts dans les
institutions politiques est défaillante
je donnerais pour preuve le baromètre de
l'ifsn un sondage qui est fait chaque
année et à la question faites vous
confiance dans les institutions
politiques pour gérer les différents
risques les résultats vont de 15 % à 40
% si finalement très faible les
résultats du d'accord est plutôt
d'accord
si on voit aux autres autre preuve de
cette défaillance de la confiance c'est
l'abstention et donc ma question c'est
que comptez vous faire pour redonner
confiance aux français dans les
institutions politiques au niveau de
l'état du gouvernement ou de tout de
tout membre de parti politique justement
pour aider à restaurer 7,5 ont pris la
bonne décision merci infiniment sur un
sujet important qui commet resterait une
société de confiance à vous bonjour à
tous alors ma question je m'appelle
gauthier de dos mais je viens de haute
marne ma question sera peut-être un
petit peu en lien avec celle de
charlotte puisque tout à l'heure j'ai le
plâtre est disait qu on ne décrète pas
une nation mais qu'on la forge et il me
semble que dans la forge des nations la
culture est une enclume essentiel et
qu'est ce que la culture au sens large
qu'elle soit artistique ou historique et
il me semble que c'est vraiment un
vecteur de rassemblement assez important
un moyen de rassembler assez important
qu'est ce qu'on propose pour recréer une
ambition culturelle qui résiste un petit
peu à aller c'est un peu facile de dire
ça mais l'américanisation de la culture
de nos jeunes aujourd'hui merci très
bien merci beaucoup
la culture
un moteur de cohésion sociale une
dernière question cette première série
ensuite je donne la parole à bonjour moi
cette nouvelle celle d'anna aussi membre
des jeunes et leurs deux départements de
l'eure alors ma question concerne
particulièrement l'intégration des
étrangers exposé le père enfance ici
aujourd'hui nous constatons que dans
certains département à une forte
concentration des étrangers
extra-européens
qui pose c'est un problème d'intégration
donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
comptez mettre à nouveau comme moyen est
également est ce que vous partagez la
vie par exemple danemark du dharma pour
les 30% d'étrangers chaque quartier
particulièrement voilà merci
merci beaucoup alors cinq questions une
sur l'éducation une sur la restauration
d'une société de confiance une sur les
questions d'intégration et sur notre
ambition culturelle évidemment sur
l'éducation alors à qui l'honneur
sachant qu évidemment là encore nous
avons des propositions mais ce qui
compte c'est de nous expliquer comment
est ce qu'on les met en oeuvre voilà
concrètement mon cher damien à toi la
parole peut-être sur les question
d'autorité de suite tu le souhaites
et d'intégration peut-être que
françois-xavier répondra plus sur les
questions d'éducation et de culture mais
de régalien aussi il n'y a pas de sujet
de prédilection normal qu'un disque
peut-être je vais je vais répondre
effectivement sur sur la question de la
société de confiance et comment on fait
pour réussir et mettre en oeuvre le
projet politique que l'on a que l'on
apporté d'abord ce projet il existe et
moi je veux saluer tous celles et tous
ceux qui sont engagés pour porter
justement ces idées ce projet politique
pour le mettre en oeuvre d'abord il faut
de la volonté il faut du courage il faut
de l'envié de la détermination
le problème pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
vous savez ce que nous reproche les
français parfois c'est pas que on a été
trop peu à droite quand on était en
responsabilité c'est qu'on n'a pas
parfois assumer suffisamment nos
convictions et nos valeurs quand on
était en responsabilité et donc il faut
pouvoir pour cela avoir ce pacte de
confiance d'abord ça promet ça commence
par dire ce que l'on fait et fait ce que
l'on dit il ya des choses très concrètes
que l'on peut faire très rapidement dans
les six premiers mois à condition d'être
bien organisés à condition d'avoir un
parlement qui soit prêt et à condition
de tout ce pouvoir agir bien dans
l'intérêt de notre pays et les choses
très concrètes elles sont simples
d'abord nous l'avons dit nous avons
toujours défendu sur les questions
d'intégration sur les questions
d'immigration nous plaidons depuis
maintenant 2017 et le programme
présidentiel de françois pignon pour
instaurer des quotas d'immigration en
france comme ça existe dans d'autres
pays pour avoir une immigration choisie
pour avoir une meilleure intégration et
pour pouvoir faire en sorte tout
simplement et bien que la france soit
cette société une et indivisible
ou tout simplement la nation française
soit respectée et entendu comme tel on
peut le faire il faut avoir le courage
de modifier la constitution dès
l'arrivée au pouvoir et en
responsabilité il faut avoir le courage
tout simplement d'aller jusqu'au bout de
ses idées sur la question des retraites
là aussi nous nous racontons pas
d'histoire ou de salades ont fait pas
une réforme des retraites à six mois de
l'élection présidentielle
quand on veut vraiment réformer les
retraites on le fait en début de
quinquennat et on le fait avec du
courage politique c'est à dire qu'on
explique aux français que parce qu'on
veut pas baisser le niveau de tension
parce qu'on veut soutenir les petites
retraites parce que tout simplement on
veut revaloriser les carrières aussi h
et notamment celle des femmes eh bien on
doit travailler plus longtemps
n'oublions jamais n'oublions jamais que
la dernière grande idée de la droite la
dernière grande idée de la droite ça a
été la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires ça a été l'augmentation
du temps de travail qui a été porté à
l'époque par nicolas sarkozy et tout le
gouvernement que nous représentions et
c'est ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
faut arriver à redéfinir notre projet à
partir de nos valeurs politiques il faut
pas en faire 50 des mesures y en a
quatre ou cinq très concrète une sur le
travail pour libérer le travail une sur
les normes parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit
bien qu'on a une bureaucratie qui
malheureusement est trop importante et
le grand drame aujourd'hui des
politiques le grand drame c'est qu'avec
la judiciarisation de la ligue politique
française avec la technostructure qui
écrase tout et bien aujourd'hui le
politique n'a plus le moyen de ses
ambitions
quand vous êtes maire vous pouvez encore
agir au quotidien quand vous êtes
président du département vous avez
encore des responsabilités pourra lire
quand vous êtes président de région vous
avez des moyens pour mettre en oeuvre
votre programme malheureusement
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes président de
la république quand vous êtes à
l'assemblée nationale eh bien vous vous
trouvez dans un carcan administratif
technocratique qui empêche le politique
de décider eh bien il ya un principe
simple c'est qu'il faut redonner aux
politiques ça capacité d'agir fortement
avec courage autour de quatre cinq
grands thèmes et c'est comme cela avec
ses 4,5 grande proposition de loi qu'il
faut faire dans le début de mandat qu'on
pourra changer les choses et montrer
tout simplement et bien que on peut pas
simplement dire mais on peut surtout
faire et c'est ça l'enjeu c'est de faire
et la confiance on la retrouvera pas en
claquant des doigts la confiance en la
retrouvera avec les résultats seuls les
résultats comptent seul le fait tout
simplement que la droite assume ses
convictions quand elle est en
responsabilité
c'est facile de l'assumer quand on est
sur une estrade à travers un micro c'est
un peu plus difficile quand on est en
responsabilité est bien quand on est de
droite on assume tout y compris quand on
est la responsabilité c'est comme ça que
redonnera la confiance aux français
merci damien
[Applaudissements]
oui haussier
oui c'est bon redonner la confiance
aussi c'est peut-être réintroduire de la
proximité dans les décisions et c'est
pas devant le président du sénat et
devant mes collègues qui sont là qui
vont me dédire aujourd'hui ce qui manque
aussi c'est qu'on a des décisions qui
sont centralisés et qui ne sont pas
adaptés ensuite au cas particulier de
chacun de chaque territoire de chaque
entreprise donc il faut vraiment qu'on
arrive à quitter le prisme d'un état
fort qui fait ou qui dit tout qui décide
tout pour laisser et donner plus
d'initiatives plus de liberté aux
personnes qui sont les plus près qui
sont celles qui vont faire et on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui les maires sont les
élus locaux qui en qui les citoyens ont
le plus confiance c'est ceux qui sont le
plus aimé pourquoi parce qu'on peut
facilement leur parler parce qu'ils
prennent des décisions qui nous
concernent directement donc aujourd'hui
aussi notre état il souffre d'être trop
fort de de tout décider pour nous d'être
omnipotent notre projet c'est aussi
justement de définir quelques priorités
qui seront celles de l'état et lab sur
ces points là il sera fort il sera
stratège et surtout le reste il sera
souple et y laissera les échelons au
plus près de l'exécution décidé et faire
cette question de la confiance soit
qu'elle est fondamental parce qu'il n'y
a pas de vie politique sans confiance
quand on ne croit plus la parole
publique alors la vie politique se
dissout de l'intérieur et quand la
politique se défait alors nécessairement
c'est la confrontation qui revient et
dans cette érosion de la confiance il
faut bien le reconnaître le quinquennat
actuel a une responsabilité très lourde
je me tourne vers gérard larcher qui
incarne la solidité du sénat le respect
des institutions aura été affaiblis
comme jamais auparavant par la manière
dont le président de la république a
mené ce quinquennat on se souvient quand
même du célèbre balances ton maire qui
avant que la crise des gis les jeunes
n'arrivent témoignaient de cette
violence que le pouvoir que l'état à
christine tu le disais pouvait avoir à
l'égard des élus locaux qui pourtant
tienne notre pays j'ai été marqué hier
de voir plusieurs jeunes républicains
qui sont élus locaux certains qui sont
maires de leur ville depuis les
dernières élections et je crois que
c'est le mandat le plus important pour
reconstruire la confiance parce que la
confiance elle commence par le terrain
par l'action et pas par l'emphase de la
communication à laquelle on a eu droit
au cours des dernières années je
voudrais revenir sur la question de
l'éducation et je suis marqué de voir à
quel point sur cette première salve de
questions vous avez parlé d'éducation de
culture d'intégration je crois que ce
sont là les sujets majeurs pour notre
avenir bien sûr et c'est important notre
projet fait une part décisive aux
questions budgétaires aux questions
régaliennes mais à la fin des fins la
grande question est qu'est-ce qui nous
relient les uns aux autres comment nous
projetons nous ensemble dans l'avenir
comme un peuple qui est conscient de ce
qui fait son unité et cette question là
c'est la question de l'éducation c'est
la question majeure pour l'avenir je me
tourne vers annie qui travaillait cette
question depuis très longtemps et je
crois que nous avons là un combat
essentiel il faut reconstruire notre
école et j'ai fait effectivement
quelques propositions pour compléter
celle que notre famille politique avait
fait pour les appuyer aussi je crois que
nous avons besoin de tout concentrer sur
l'école primaire sur les savoirs
fondamentaux jean michel blanquer elle a
dit jean michel blanquer ne l'a pas fait
nous avons besoin ensuite de mieux
former les professeurs de mieux les
recruter de mieux les rémunérer et
n'ayons pas peur de le dire aujourd'hui
cette crise de l'école elle vient de
loin elle vient aussi du fait que depuis
longtemps nous n'avons pas pris soin de
ceux qui font le travail de la
transmission l'enseignement je parle un
peu pour ma corporation mais c'est le
métier le plus essentiel pour qu'un pays
puisse avoir confiance dans son avenir
et puis je voudrais dire un mot enfin
des étudiants parce que vous êtes
nombreux ici à être étudiant et hier
j'ai été frappée en échangeant avec vous
des témoignages que beaucoup d'entre
vous me partage et de la souffrance que
traverse beaucoup d'étudiants l'une
d'entre vous me disait même avec des
mots très forts je ne sais pas si elle
est là ce matin le désespoir dans lequel
vivent beaucoup d'étudiants aujourd'hui
leur sentiment de solitude ce sentiment
il est lié bien sûr à la crise que nous
traversons dont les jeunes ont été les
premières victimes
parce que les choix collectifs que nous
avons fait on réduit beaucoup d'entre
eux à une forme de distance de
distanciation permanente d'avec leurs
études avec leurs amis avec leurs amphis
et nous avons besoin aujourd'hui de
redire que un pays ne peut pas avoir
d'avenir s'il ne donne pas la priorité à
sa jeunesse c'est à cause de la crise
actuelle mais c'est aussi à cause d'une
crise plus durable dans les dix
dernières années les dépenses de l' ocde
pour les pour l'enseignement supérieur
ont augmenté de 10% en france elles ont
baissé de 8% ça veut dire que nous
suivons une trajectoire absurde dans
laquelle nous sommes en train de
sacrifier notre avenir pour des dépenses
de court terme nous avons un état qui
est massivement endettés une dépense
publique pléthorique et pourtant nous
avons des universités paupérisée des
professeurs d'université des charges et
télé qui ont du mal à faire leur travail
et des étudiants qui travaillent dans
des conditions qui sont objectivement
indigne d'un pays développés nous avons
une recherche qui est trop fragile qui
est trop faible pour que nous puissions
peser dans le monde de demain et écrire
notre histoire plutôt que de la subir
tout misé sur les étudiants et les
rejoindre là où ils sont c'est le défi
devant lequel nous sommes si nous
voulons reconstruire une france qui ait
conscience de son unité et qu'ils
puissent avoir confiance en son avenir
merci françois xavier
merci à tous les trois pour la concision
de réponse j'espère que j'aurai des
questions aussi concise que les réponses
encore cinq questions voyons encore
trente minutes devant nous donc allez-y
ya pas de mauvaises questions toutes les
questions sont bonnes profitez-en on est
là je vous en prie merci bonjour
abraham lincoln présenter la démocratie
comme le gouvernement du peuple par le
peuple et pour le peuple
aujourd'hui on a une crise de la
représentation comme l'a montré marianne
quand des qui est professeur de droit il
me semble en fait beaucoup de citoyens
ne se sentent plus représentés ont
l'impression que le politique est loin
de ne les aide pas ne leur apporte pas
de solution
alors concrètement comment faire pour
résoudre cette crise de la
représentation est ce qu'il faut
accroître la participation des citoyens
dans le débat politique et dans la prise
des décisions que ce soit au niveau
local au niveau national comment faire
en fait pour que les citoyens se sentent
investis et l'impression est le
sentiment que le politique qui leur
apporte des solutions
merci pour cette question très
importante qui concerne en effet la
réconciliation des français avec leurs
gouvernants deuxième question
allez-y je vous en prie alors bonjour je
suis emeline de la ville de paris ma
question est la suivante en fait en a en
fait un constat c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
discours extrémistes de tous bords
s'accaparent le débat public on n'entend
plus que l'extrémisme comment en fait
combattre la démesure sans tomber dans
la demi mesure et comment justement
apporter de la nuance dans le débat avec
fermeté parce qu'il faut pas confondre
la fermeté l'extrémisme donc comment
être nuancée et arriver à faire entendre
sa voix avec clarté merci beaucoup très
très bonne question
les très profonde une troisième question
là je vois qu'il ya une file d'attenté
là bas allez-y poser les doigts sans
couronne je m'appelle teom sad il suit
le rdj des hautes-pyrénées et je voulais
parler d'un sujet qui me tient à coeur
c'est les autres vers il constitue pour
moi un véritable bijou pour la france et
sa forme en partie de l'exception
française puisque la france constitue
l'une des dernières des dernières
grandes nations qui a un territoire
présente partout dans le monde dans
presque tous les océans et je voulais
vraiment penser à aujourd'hui et ma
question a été simple a été clair
c'était nous en 2022 quand nous serons
au pouvoir quels seront les états
qu'elles seront l'état parlons d outre
mer quels seront les tas de mayotte avec
les bidonvilles parce que je pense qu'on
peut pas se targuer d'être la sixième
puissance mondiale et d'avoir encore des
citoyens français qui vivent dans des
bidonvilles donc qu'allons nous ferait
sans les outre-mer merci beaucoup très
très bon niveau de questions a les yeux
encore de questions
bonjour non et clément chercheurs en
astrophysique j'ai une question pour
monsieur bel ami mais plus largement
pour tout le monde
on a des étudiants qui sont un bac + 3 à
bac + 5 qui ne trouvent pas de travail
en adéquation avec les compétences
qu'ils ont acquises à l'université mais
à côté de ça on a des artisans qui ne
trouvent pas d'apprentis on a des
sapeurs pompiers qui cherche
désespérément à recruter
on va manquer de vendangeurs cette année
encore comment dire à notre génération
comment dire aux jeunes que ces métiers
que cas parfois on qualifie de manuels
sont des beau métier qu'on peut s'y
épanouir et que ce n'est pas toujours
avec les compétences qu'on a acquise à
l'université on trouvera pas toujours
une profession dans cette danse dans
cette voie et que voilà il ya des
diables d'abord adapter les filières
professionnelles entre guillemets aux
besoins de la vie éco alors que comment
revaloriser les métiers d'artisanat et
les métiers manuels une filière d
l'excellent serait bien très bonne
question
à bout
bonjour
alors je m'appelle julien font quand je
suis membre du conseil départemental de
la vienne à poitiers ma question portait
sur l'éducation notamment l'éducation
chez les jeunes puisque en effet les
écoles et les collèges sont très
tributaires et dépendent des
bureaucrates de la laitue deux bons
de là
c'est juste un je vous en prie de
l'inspection académique et du coup je me
demandais comment est-ce qu'on peut
donner plus de marge de liberté
d'autonomie aux chefs d'établissement
qui eux sont plus proches des élèves et
des familles des élèves que les
bureaucrates
très bien merci infiniment donc on a là
cinq questions crise de représentation
comment donc essayer de nuancer un peu
le débat public
l'outre-mer la correspondance donc des
filières professionnelles avec les
besoins de la vie économique est donc là
cette dernière question qui commence
devrait revenir très vite sur sur la
représentation je pense que ce
gouvernement est le premier à vouloir
faire passer outre le parlement et les
chambres représentative et à l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat il ya aussi le
conseil économique et social
environnemental on a décidé de créer des
comités de citoyens alors vous avez
forcément tous entendu parler de la
convention citoyenne vous avez peut-être
un peu moins entendu parler du comité
citoyen pour la suivi de la vaccination
parce qu'on ne sait pas trop ce qu'il a
fait depuis que les gens ont été choisis
mais je voudrais juste revenir sur
l'exemple de la convention citoyenne
lait conventionnel se sont réunis ils
ont le sentiment d'avoir bien travaillé
ils se sont chacun engagés pleinement
comme un parlementaire pourrait le faire
ils ont établi des propositions et pour
eux ces propositions elles valaient
argent comptant elle devait être ensuite
votée les yeux pas refermées parlement
par le parlementaire il s'avère que j'ai
rapporté pour une partie de ce texte est
un parlementaire quand il est saisi d'un
projet de loi il ne fait pas son travail
les yeux fermés il ya un véritable
travail d'approfondissement de questions
non il reçoit l'ensemble des parties
prenantes de la société les acteurs
économiques les représentants des
consommateurs les usagers et donc on
s'est rendu compte que le travail que
les conventionnels avait fait en croyant
agir vraiment du mieux qu'il le pouvait
en fait tout ne leur avait pas été
présenté donc en pensant par exemple
légiférer sur l'interdiction du
plastique et des emballages de telle
nature il n'avait absolument pas penser
les conséquences pour le domaine de
l'agroalimentaire rien pour le transport
des denrées donc on voit bien qu
effectivement c'est les citoyens doivent
être là il doit pouvoir exprimer leurs
attentes et ça ils le font au moment où
ils vont voter à partir du moment où les
différents partis politiques sont aussi
transparent avec et annonce clairement
ce qu'ils vont faire ensuite et ensuite
une fois qu'ils ont désigné des
représentants il faut leur faire
confiance et leur laisser le temps de
travailler puisque la loi ne se fait pas
comme ça d'un coup de baguette magique
c'est vraiment un très long travail
d'appropriation des changes pour être
sûr que ce qui est ensuite écrit et qui
forment notre droit soit applicable
parfait
mon cher d'amiens
un mot d'abord sur la question qui a été
posée sur l'artisanat et et la question
finalement de l'intelligence de la main
pour moi le l'un des plus grands drames
éducatif en france c'est quand on a
voulu amener 80 90 % d'une classe d'âge
au bac la vérité c'est qu'on a tué le
bac et la vérité c'est qu'on a affaibli
nos universités françaises
et c'est symbolique de ce que la gauche
et c'est à dire l'égalitarisme à
outrance où tous vos tours où tout est
égal à tous une société d'aplatissement
des valeurs vous n'avez plus le droit de
noter les élèves vous n'avez plus droit
finalement de mettre en place des
bourses au mérite vous avez plus droit
de récompenser des parcours méritant
vous avez plus droit de porter les
valeurs de la république bien la
première chose à faire c'est déjà de
changer cette culture là d'expliquer
aujourd'hui aux français que comme ça se
fait en allemagne quand on est apprenti
on peut demain devenir ingénieur et on
peut aussi être apprenti et réussir sa
vie bien entendu dessarzin en jeu après
un wagon d'un mental
[Musique]
et vous savez moi je je viens d'un
département dans l'ain avec cette belle
région auvergne rhône-alpes présidée par
laurent wauquiez où on a fait ensemble
ensemble
départements et régions on a rétabli les
bourses au mérite
ensemble on a aussi fait en sorte tout
simplement qu' on puisse remettre des
programmes de valeur la république et
surtout moi j'appartiens au premier
département industriel de france et
aujourd'hui je peux vous le dire ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure et qui est
très juste qui est de dire mais on
manque de main d'oeuvre j'ai aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'entreprises en notre
département est partout en france qui ne
trouve plus de main d'oeuvre qui ne
trouvent plus de main-d'oeuvre
suffisamment présents sur territoire
français vous parliez tout à l'heure des
vendangeurs j'étais encore avant-hier
soir avec des viticulteurs du budget ils
m'ont dit exactement ce que vous venez
de dire est donc par rapport à ça qu'est
ce qu'on fait et bien un effectivement
on cassait tigali taris mme culturel et
éducatif qui abîme la société française
deuxièmement on renforce l'intelligence
de la main et on montre que quand on est
en alternance cantons et des parcours
d'apprentissage c'est pas honteux
au contraire c'est valorisant et on a
courage cela également
et puis
enfin il
faut aussi qu'on se parle franchement il
faut aussi que le travail soit valorisée
il n'est pas acceptable aujourd'hui dans
notre pays que parfois et bien il vaut
mieux rester au rsa cumuler un certain
nombre de dispositifs plutôt que de
faire un parcours de retour vers
l'emploi je vous le dis comme je le
pense quand on est de droite on ne
défend pas le rsa pour tous quand on est
de droite entre-temps le travail pour
tous
[Musique]
et j'en termine temps là mais moi j'en
ai assez d'entendre j'en ai assez
d'entendre dire que finalement le
président de la république il fait une
politique de droite sur le plan
économique on n'a jamais eu autant de
dettes et de déficits qu'aujourd'hui
alors nous dit oui miel qu'ovide
d'accord et l'allemagne ils ont pas eu
la copie et la grande bretagne ils ont
pas eu la coved et l'italie et l'espagne
ils ont pas eu la copie la réalité c'est
quoi c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
mille 800 milliards d'euros de dettes de
1800 par la réalité c'est que nous avons
118 % du produit intérieur brut de
dettes c'est ça la réalité la réalité
c'est qu'en trois mois en trois mois la
dette française a explosé de 90
milliards d'euros eh bien je suis désolé
quand on est de droite on peut pas se
satisfaire de cette économie asphyxiés
par la pompe à fric permanente par la
promesse permanente aussi alléchante
soit est on assume aussi la maîtrise de
dépenses publiques et la lutte contre le
gaspillage d'argent public
merci damien françois-xavier bon damien
écrit sinon ont répondu à toutes les
questions j'y allais avec perfection et
oui il faut parler un mot de l'outre-mer
peut-être pour revenir sur ce que disait
damien l'instant non seulement cette
explosion des dépenses publiques est un
danger pour l'avenir et pour votre
avenir en particulier parce qu'elle
était une manière un peu égoïste de
reporter sur vous le poids des problèmes
qui ne sont pas résolus aujourd'hui mais
c'est aussi un problème parce que c'est
la clé d'une mauvaise gestion quelqu'un
disait tout à l'heure comment faire en
sorte qu' on puisse libérer les énergies
par exemple dans l'éducation nationale
il arrive à l'éducation nationale la
même tragédie qu'à l'hôpital la même
tragédie qu'a l'agriculteur ya plus de
fonctionnaires qui s'occupe de
l'agriculture dans les bureaux que de
gens qui laboure la terre il ya plus de
gens aujourd'hui que nulle part ailleurs
en europe dans l'administration de
l'éducation nationale comparé au nombre
de professeurs qui sont sur le terrain
aujourd'hui l'éducation nationale c'est
un million de fonctionnaires vous en
avez 200 à 250 milles qui ne sont pas
devant des élèves et le problème c'est
cette sueur administration qui à la fois
coûte cher évidemment mais qui aussi
asphyxier les énergies et qui empêchent
d'agir et de rémunérer correctement ceux
qui travaillent sur le terrain donc ça
c'est un sujet majeur sur la question de
la sur la question de l'apprentissage
sur la question de l'apprentissage tout
a été dit je pense qu'il ya aussi une
question de culture il faut pas toujours
tout refaire peser sur la faute des
politiques il ya aussi une culture que
nous avons à transformer en france tout
a commencé avec la loi jospin en effet
qui disait qu'il fallait non seulement m
80 % d'une classe d'âge au bac mais 50 %
d'une classe d'âge avec un diplôme de
l'enseignement supérieur la vérité c'est
que les systèmes scolaires qui
réussissent le mieux en europe et qui
ont à la fin les taux d'emploi les plus
importants pour les jeunes sont ceux
dans lequel l'aspiration au diplôme de
l'enseignement supérieur sont les moins
développés et c'est ce qu'ils produisent
le meilleur socle de culture générale
chez les élèves donc il faut qu'on
arrive à transformer notre regard moi
j'ai été prof en lycée hôtelier j'ai été
prof en lycée technologique
j'ai été prof en classe de sti génie
électrotechnique et génie mécanique et
je peux vous dire quand je démarre ma
voiture le matin je suis content que
tout le monde ne soit pas prof de philo
il faut admirer il faut estimer il faut
s'émerveiller
excellence de nos artisans de notre
industrie de nos entreprises de nos
savoir faire et bien sûr qu'il faut des
gens qui bien sûr qu'il faut des gens
qui s'engagent dans l'astrophysique
comme vous et vous poser cette question
vous même avec votre bagage est votre
parcours mais il faut aussi que
l'excellence puissent être reconnues et
admirées dans tous les domaines et dans
toutes les versions que nous pouvons lui
donner et puis un dernier mot peut-être
sur l'autre mère je crois que c'est
effectivement un sujet majeur notre
famille politique est historiquement
celle qui avec jacques chirac celle qui
avec les présidents de la république qui
se sont succédé à porter ce liens de la
france avec ces départements ces
territoires d'outre-mer et je crois que
c'est très important pour nous aussi au
parlement européen je le dis avec agnès
nous travaillons beaucoup sur les
régions ultrapériphériques parce que
nous avons besoin de reconnecter la
france de reconnecter l'europe à ces
territoires j'ai été à mayotte j'ai été
à la réunion nous continuerons d'aller
dans les départements et les territoires
d'outre-mer parce que nous avons
tellement à investir là-bas vous parliez
de mayotte on peut parler de l'éducation
à mayotte à majorque il faudrait ouvrir
une classe par jour pour accueillir les
élèves dans de bonnes conditions et donc
on a un vrai sujet de rattrapage des
investissements à faire enfin un dernier
mot je voudrais dire un immense merci à
amine
je ne sais pas s'il est toujours là je
me trompe pas sur ton prénom amine la
formule que tu as prononcée elle
pourrait servir de devise à l'engagement
politique lutter contre la démesure sans
tomber dans la demi mesure je la retiens
je vais la méditer
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est
je pense que c'est un défi majeur pour
nous aujourd'hui parce qu'on vit un
moment où et c'est aussi un sujet
éducatif on le voit dans les débats qui
tourne autour de la question du vaccin
du pain sanitaires sur laquelle on peut
avoir des regards différents mais je
crois qu'on voit malheureusement le
grand drame que représente
l'effondrement de la rationalité l'excès
permanent le remplacement des arguments
par les invectiver par les insultes et
nous nous la famille politique de la
droite et du centre nous avons une
responsabilité majeure qui est
d'incarner une opposition claire et
ferme à la politique menée par le
gouvernement tue le disait damien nous
ne serons pas ne seront jamais celui
dans le maquereau nisme sans jamais
céder à l'excès sans jamais céder à l'un
à l'invectivé sans jamais tomber dans le
mensonge dans la caricature dans la
fausseté permanente et c'est un défi
difficile je crois que nous devons
absolument incarner cela reconnaît sur
le lutter contre la montée de cette
espèce de radicalisation ça suppose que
nous soyons fidèles à ce que nous sommes
d'abord parce que nous avons le devoir
de garder une ligne claire d'être loyaux
dans la compétition politique d'être
intellectuellement honnête de chercher
la vérité et non pas les excès ça
suppose aussi que nous soyons fidèles à
nous mêmes parce que reconnaissons le ce
qui a fait monter les extrêmes parfois
ce sont nos propres contradictions
ce sont nos propres manquements ce sont
nos propres au silence et ce sont de ces
fautes que nous avons pu commettre
parfois que les extrêmes se sont nourris
pour pouvoir se faire passer pour les
seules alternatives possibles rester
fidèle à une ligne claire à une ligne
exigeante rester fidèles à nos
convictions continuer de les défendre
envers et contre tout c'est ce qui fera
que demain j'en suis sûr nous pourrons
montrer que la seule solution crédible
pour que la france retrouve une
espérance c'est celle de cet équilibre
que tu évoquais l'instant c'est que nous
pouvons incarner merci beaucoup merci
françois xavier
tu as très bien fait de citer les
oppositions qui parfois tiennent des
discours en effet excessif mais
l'exemple il doit de il doit venir
également du sommet de l'état quand on a
un président de la république qui traite
les français de gaulois réfractaires de
ceux qui ne sont rien c'est sûr que ça
ne donne pas l'exemple et donc au sommet
de l'état on aimerait de temps en temps
un peu plus d'humilité de modestie
alors je vois qu'il ya plus de questions
comment c'est possible est ce que j'ai
encore des questions dans la salle
allez-y je vais trouver un choix qui est
toulousain sur la gauche
bonjour je m'appelle martin becker je
suis étudiant en droit et je suis à la
section lr toulouse et je me posais une
question sur la thématique de rassembler
rassembler les gens c'est les contacts
entre les individus comme les et
saint-exupéry la civilisation ce sont
les contacts pour l'entretien entre les
gens mais également je pense que
rassembler passe par la loi or lorsque
j'ai commencé mes études de droit on va
parler d'un concept qui me fascinait à
savoir l'anomie c'est-à-dire l'individu
qui n'intègre pas la loi en lui et donc
qui l'empêchent de l'appliquer parce
qu'il ne la comprend pas finalement ou
du moins qu'il ne l'a pas intégré qu'il
n'en comprend pas le bien aussi lorsque
j'appris cela je pensais que c'était
limité à quelques lointaines banlieues
où quelques quartiers dont je dois
admettre je n'ai jamais vraiment côtoyer
et que j'essayais d'éviter le soir quand
je prenais le métro seulement récemment
avec la politique de l'aco vide avec la
politique du gouvernement je me suis
rendu compte que moi même et les gens
autour de moi et les gens que je
côtoyais commencé à douter et à ne plus
comprendre de cette même manière et à
tomber justement en cette forme de
complotisme alors ça revient sur la
question de comment faire pour que les
gens retrouvent confiance dans leurs
gouvernants donc les rapprocher comme on
l'a déjà dit mais également me retrouve
confiance dans la loi et dans ce qui
fait l'état finalement merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup c'est très clair
à vous madame
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle romaine le priol je
viens du territoire de belfort
j'ai une question aujourd'hui par
rapport à l'actualité brûlante qui est
finalement concernant les incendies qui
sont en constante augmentation et qui
risquent de s'intensifier durant les
années à venir donc j'aurais aimé savoir
comment frontier pouvoir protéger les
populations d'en face à ces risques qui
vont être en constante augmentation
merci beaucoup encore trois questions
derrière ce sera ce seront les dernières
oui bonjour pierre garrec délégué de la
7e circonscription du finistère
je voulais revenir poser de questions un
petit peu provocatrice alors je sais pas
si elles sont dans la démesure mais il
s'agit pas de demi mesure en tout cas
revenir notamment sur ce qui a été dit
en matière d'immigration choisie
et permettrait d'intégrer vos réponses
mix nous avons un débat dans la
circonscription sur les questions de
d'insécurité de délinquance et
d'immigration et en tant qu'ancien chef
de service de l'état j'avais entre
autres les questions de relatives aux
demandes aux demandeurs d'asile première
question est ce qu'il ne faut pas
revenir sur le rapprochement familial et
deuxième question est ce qu'il ne faut
pas revenir peut-être sur une vieille
tradition française mais les traditions
ça change on est revenu sur le droit
d'asile sur les privilèges de la
noblesse et sur d'autres c'est la
question du droit du sol voilà
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
d'abord je voudrais vous remercier
d'être si nous avoue nos élus les
invités les organisateurs les jeunes
pour ce dialogue ce dialogue fondamental
je pense non seulement pour
l'enrichissement personnel certes mais
surtout la cohésion nationale
ensuite je voudrais faire cette prise de
parole mettre en valeur une enquête
celle du programme international du
suivi des acquis qui met en valeur que
la france avec deux autres pays fait
partie sur 79 autres pays où il ya le
plus de problème de discipline pendant
les cours instinctivement j'ai pensé au
chef d'orchestre britannique
harry daniel harding qui reprochait à
son directeur musical de venir faire son
travail et de s'en aller il voulait
qu'ils s'investissent davantage et pour
avoir une rayonnante et qu'à l'extérieur
alors je voulais vous poser cette
question
qu'est ce que vous pensez du fait que à
la dimension théorique déjà fortement
installé dans l'éducation nationale
d'ajouter une pratique qui passerait à
l'adhésion à une association à
peu importe peu importe qu est ce que ça
ait du moment que l'enfant se sent
épanoui à l'intérieur et donc l'objectif
serait que les enfants ne se sentent pas
dans une école oui ils ne font pas
partie du système éducatif français mais
de leur système éducatif français trois
questions à l'est encore deux dernières
et ensuite
en soi que ces jours ci des cobourg a
kiss ancien chef de l'entreprise
il ya 50 ans mon père était en
afghanistan les afghans se réclamait de
l'europe de la civilisation européenne
est aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on pourrait
défendre notre civilisation et notre
république et
voir les erreurs que nous avons commises
depuis entre autres en 1971 la
modification n'est rentré dans la 6ème
république
la cour constitutionnelle au lieu de
juger la constitution de façon stricte
aux sangsues la juge de face au lantus
lato sensu ce qui fait une modification
constitutionnelle majeure
merci beaucoup dernière question
sacha 17 en avant face à un impérialisme
économique et culturel croissant de la
part des gars femme je pense
naturellement à amazon comment la france
peut-elle lutter pour se protéger
quelles mesures protectionnistes et
qu'elle aide les pouvoirs publics
peuvent-ils mettre en place pour lutter
efficacement contre une concurrence
parfois déloyale les néfastes à notre
terroir à notre artisanat et à notre
culture très bonne question et laissez
pas structuré
alors je pense qu'on va commencer par un
sujet qui vous tient le plus à coeur
avec français cas de bellamy comment
redonner envie aux enfants aux étudiants
de se réapproprier l'école de de refaire
partie de cette entité qui nous forme
tous et qui est notre socle commun et
qui définit notre devenir
décidément on aura beaucoup parlé
d'éducation ce matin et je pense est une
très bonne nouvelle parce qu'encore une
fois c'est vraiment le sujet majeur pour
l'avenir comment redonner envie aux
enfants d'adhérer à l'école moi je vous
dis à une chose très simple je n'ai
jamais rencontré d'élèves qui médit qu'
il ne voulait pas participer au projet
de l'enseignement qu'il ne voulait pas
recevoir ce que nous avions à leur
transmettre ce que j'ai vécu c'est que
dans ma formation d'enseignants on m'a
expliqué qu'il fallait pas transmettre
un savoir qu'il fallait que les élèves
puissent construire leurs propres savoir
quand je vais écouter ce qui se dit à la
radio ou à la télévision où j'entends le
président de la république qui dit qu'il
n'y a pas de culture française et c'est
pas les élèves qui dit ça même les
élèves issus de l'immigration
c'est dans le discours ambiant dans
celui qu'on entend parfois de la part de
la génération des adultes et non pas de
la génération des jeunes qu'on nous
explique que notre culture transmettre
notre culture ce serait un acte
ethnocentriste ou néo colonial que la
littérature est sexiste qu'il faut
transformer la langue comme le dit jean
luc mélenchon la langue qu'on dit
française qu' il faudrait
s'enthousiasmer comme le disait encore
le même jean luc mélenchon de la
créolisation qui viendraient
déconstruire la langue française que au
fond ces crises de culture cette crise
de la transmission moi je peux le dire
comme professeur elle ne vient pas des
jeunes elle ne vient pas des enfants
quand vous venez devant des élèves en
leur disant j'ai quelque chose à vous
apprendre qu'il mérite d'être reçu c'est
le début d'une relation qui est
évidemment toujours difficile parce que
ça n'est jamais facile la relation
pédagogique ça n'est jamais facile la
relation éducative mais c'est toujours
le début d'une relation passionnée par
ce que ce que désirent les jeunes ce qui
ce qui les anime ce à quoi ils inspirent
ces à rejoindre quelque chose de plus
grand qu'eux en quoi ils puissent se
reconnaître et c'est ce que
reconnaissons le malheureusement dans
beaucoup de nos quartiers l'islamisme a
su faire sur le vide que la république a
laissé derrière elle nous n'avons pas su
vous le disiez monsieur parler de notre
civilisation
et parce que nous n'avons pas su parler
de notre civilisation parce que nous
n'avons rien su transmettre d'une
certaine manière alors la radicalisation
islamiste est venu remplir les coeurs et
les esprits et d'une certaine façon nous
avons ouvert la voie parce que nous
n'avons pas su proposer un idéal à
partager à ses discours absurde de haine
et de violence qui ont pris la place de
l'idéal que la france pouvait avoir à
porter je le dis avec toute notre
famille politique nous l'avons dit tout
au long de la campagne des européennes
et nous continuons de le dire au
parlement européen une france une europe
qui ne savent pas dire qu ils sont les
héritiers d'une civilisation
millénaire une france qui ne s'est pas
nommé ses racines qui ne s'est pas parlé
de son histoire qui ne s'est pas être
fière de ce qu'elle est est une france
qui n'a pas d'avenir si elle ne retrouve
pas son lien avec son passé
[Applaudissements]
et je crois que le mot le mot
civilisation a été prononcée plusieurs
fois ici civilisation vous citiez
saint-exupéry c'est non pas les choses
mais incertaine arrangement entre les
êtres qui fait qu'ils sont liés ainsi et
non autrement c'est exactement de ce
lien que nous avons besoin si nous
voulons vaincre le danger de l'archipel
isation de la france nous avons besoin
de retrouver le sens de ce lien commun
et je le redis encore une fois pour cela
nous avons besoin de vous vous pouvez
compter sur nous mais c'est vous qui
êtes la voix dont nous avons besoin pour
reconstruire le lien partout sur les
territoires dans les facs dans les
amphis dans vos lieux de travail dans
vos lieux de stage vous est ce qu'ils
peuvent dire cela qu'ils peuvent
partager ce message si souvent
caricaturée si souvent traîné dans la
boue vous êtes ce qu'ils peuvent dire
aujourd'hui que oui nous croyons que ce
qui nous lie quelles que soient nos
différences quelles que soient nos
divergences c'est quelque chose de plus
grand que nous qui a vocation à durer
qui a vocation à demeurer et qui
s'appelle la france et c'est ce que nous
avons à défendre aussi comme une famille
politique unis au cours de cette
élection présidentielle
[Musique]
alors vous vous montrez une transition
parfaite sur la transmission et
l'intégration à cette nation fait
devenir français est-ce qu'on devrait
revenir sur le droit du sol et sur la
politique de rapprochement familial
damien abad s'il vous plaît
merci bon d'abord sur la question du
droit du sol qui a été posée tout à
l'heure c'est une question importante et
on a cité mayotte ben voilà un exemple
concret où je pense que le droit du sol
à mayotte ne fonctionne absolument plus
et que donc on doit avoir cette attaque
cette adaptation là au moins dans un
premier temps déjà pour mayotte et
ensuite se poser la question quand j'ai
parlé d'immigration choisie
j'ai eu la chance avec quelques
parlementaires de me rendre au canada
avec un modèle qui est constituée qui
est je trouve intéressante même s'il
n'est pas totalement adaptable à la
france mais qui est de dire tout
simplement et bien que la force de ce
pays c'est que il choisit son
immigration est donc bien sûr et la
question économique mais la migration
familiale doit être également posé et
vous le savez on a beaucoup d'accords
d'association avec un certain nombre de
pays qui fait que malheureusement
parfois c'est compliqué pour aboutir à
des résultats concrets donc je pense que
là dessus il faut ni angélisme ni
stigmatisation
il faut tout simplement affirmé défendre
nos valeurs et faire en sorte aussi mais
je pense que françois-xavier pourrait le
dire mieux que moi d'avoir aussi une
politique migratoire qui sera construite
au niveau national mais aussi au niveau
européen on a eu tellement de donc de
jumping migratoires entre les différents
pays que malheureusement on a souffert
on le voit bien sur les dévoiements de
la procédure d'asile on le voit bien sur
la difficulté que l'on a construit les
hotspots on voit bien de la difficulté
qu'on a aujourd'hui aguessac à gérer la
question de la situation afghane qui est
effectivement une question très
difficile pour l'europe mais je le dis
très clairement
si l'europe ne résout pas à cette
question des flux migratoires
l'europe elle se fracassera sur ce sujet
là et donc ça doit être la première des
priorités je voudrais juste rebondir
pour pour conclure sur les deux sujets
qui ont été abordés la question de la
loi et la question du climat la question
de la loi était très importante en dix
ans mais comment on fait pour que les
lois soient mieux comprises et mieux
respectés en france m'a d'abord qui en
est - et ensuite qu'elles soient mieux
appliquées et mieux exécuter le drame en
france c'est qu'on pense que parce qu'on
a voté une loi on parle cette loi va
s'appliquer et on regarde jamais les
décrets d'application d'ailleurs nous
parlementaires je parle sous le contrôle
du président gérard larcher mais je
pense qu'on a un travail à faire sur
l'exécution des lois et sur le rôle des
parlementaires mais aussi de l'exécutif
dans les décrets d'application qui sont
pris parce que malheureusement et très
souvent le constate on a des lois qui
sont pas appliquées sur le terrain vous
avez vu tout à l'heure un débat etc
rachida dati sur la question de la
justice et la réforme pénale on le voit
très clairement là dessus la non
exécution des décisions de justice elle
génère un sentiment d'impunité et quand
vous avez ce sentiment d'impunité et
bien forcément vous n'avez pas cette
acceptation de la loi et l'autre point
qui est majeur sur la loi aussi c'est de
l'oubli y ont jamais que la loi est
l'expression de la volonté générale elle
ne doit pas être l'expression des
minorités agissantes aussi bruyante tu
soit elle et ça c'est aussi ça que nous
devons défendre à droite c'est à dire
cette majorité silencieuse c'est
française et ces français qui se lèvent
tôt le matin qui bossent qui ont du mal
parfois à finir les fins de mois et qui
applique la loi et qui en ont assez de
voir parfois bien des délinquants qui ne
sont pas sanctionnés et que eux quand
ils roulent dans les rues de paris
maintenant à 38 km heure au lieu de 30
eh bien ils sont sanctionnés et ils ont
une amende c'est ce deux poids deux
mesures là qui est absolument
insupportable et que nous devons
corriger aujourd'hui très clairement
[Applaudissements]
et un mot juste sur la question du
climat ça serait trop long pour pour
l'aborder mais sur ce que vous avez
évoqué des incendies qu'on a connu cet
été dans le var et ailleurs mais on
pourrait aussi évoquer tout ce qui s'est
passé sur les intempéries les
précipitations en allemagne à tous qu'on
subit au quotidien c'est pour cela que
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure en
introduction mais vous qui êtes la
jeunesse de droite on peut pas passer
acquise à côté de cette question
écologique là elle est absolument
essentielle elle est centrale et elle
doit structurer notre projet politique
d'aujourd'hui mais aussi de demain c'est
un sujet majeur est vraiment mon souhait
le plus fort c'est que la droite
s'empare de ce sujet là parce que quand
on entend les inepties quand on boit ce
que ce que lorsque l'on entend ces
insupportables donc il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire mais je voudrais
simplement dire sur les incendies et
rendre hommage quand même à celles et
ceux qui font nation et à celles et ceux
qui au quotidien cet été eh bien on pu
lutter contre les incendies se sont bien
sûr nos pompiers nos pompiers
volontaires que nos pompiers
professionnels qui font un travail
absolument remarquable et qui nous
défendent au quotidien
est juste une solde agnès puisque je
crois que c'est là il parle je voudrais
simplement conclure quand même en vous
disant ceci aussi en tant qu' en tant
que président de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale vous savez notre objectif avec
gérard avec christian avec tous celles
et tous ceux qui sont là c'est de faire
en sorte que notre famille politique et
gagne cette élection présidentielle pas
simplement pour nous pas simplement pour
vous mais d'abord pour la france parce
que cette france là aujourd'hui elle est
abîmée allés fracturer elle est archi
paix lisez comme on pourrait le dire et
aujourd'hui je considère et rachida l'a
dit tout à l'heure que certainement la
france n'a jamais été aussi à droite et
nous avons gagné la bataille culturelle
nous avons gagné sur certains points la
bataille idéologique pas surtout parce
que notre culture c'est pas le hoki sme
notre culture c'est pas l'indigénisme
mais nous avons quand même gagné une
bonne partie de nos idées mais
aujourd'hui il faut pouvoir les mettre
en oeuvre il faut pas pouvoir les mettre
en oeuvre par effraction il faut pouvoir
les mettre en oeuvre par nous mêmes
alors le souhait moi que je fais dans
cette rentrée politique et parlementaire
c'est une chose j'ai eu la chance hier
d'être côtés de autre ancien président
de la république nicolas sarkozy pour le
concert de carla brio par des oiseaux
est bien ce que j'ai envie c'est que
2022 ressemble davantage à 2007 que 2017
et pour ça il faut qu'on soit unie
rassemblée et qu'on joue collectif tous
ensemble
chef innu reste deux minutes et je
voudrais donner la parole le mot de
conclusion à charlotte la vice
présidente des jeunes républicains merci
à tous
bah écoute et merci à nos invités d'être
venu sur scène pour répondre aux
questions des jeunes merci aux jeunes
d'avoir participé à cette table ronde
d'avoir alimenté nos discussions
françois-xavier damien et christine un
grand merci merci agnès pour ta
bienveillance avec avec nous les jeunes
en tout cas
encore merci au président christian
jacob pour sa confiance qu'ils nous
accordent avec guilhem et toute l'équipe
depuis que nous avons gagné l'élection
en avril c'est vraiment un grand plaisir
de travailler que toute l'équipe et puis
bah écoutez je vous souhaite un très bon
appétit puisque c'est l'heure d'aller
manger et
[Applaudissements]
et on se retrouve ici à 14 heures il me
semble pour une table comment
14h30 pour table-ronde avec gérard
larcher et christian jacob merci
beaucoup